there's one thing I hate and that's to
be a hypocrite and I kind of feel like I
became a little bit of one with my
Britney video the other day so I want to
just fix it in the little way I mean I
believe in every message I sent to the
Britney team and Lauren thank you so
much for leaving a comment in the last
post the way you've been handling that
account lately he's been awesome by the
way I think you should separate it by
the way team Britney and the real
Britney let the real Britney just
Twitter out from that and have a team
Britney and do that I'm sure many people
follow both but let's be honest Barack
Obama I have to call you out if I call
out Britney and again first and foremost
this is the first and foremost I don't
really expect anybody to have to listen
to me I just enjoy sharing my thoughts I
like doing this it's something I'm
passionate about I think um I think what
I'm doing with it is a lot of fun I
think a lot of other people are doing a
great job with it but please you know I
get it I mean Britney Spears definitely
doesn't need to listen to me she's a
much bigger brand she does quite well
though she is rebranding and this is
momentum to me you know just cuz you're
a huge brand doesn't mean that you
shouldn't use the tools in a way that
can help you now what defines help you
is everybody's own definition not
necessarily mine but I truly believe
that if you're using a Twitter account
it is an amazing way to be very
authentic and so Barack Obama has a
Twitter account he's the most followed
person on Twitter and it is very obvious
that he is not the person twittering so
if we're gonna call out Britney
Internet's
let's call out Barack Obama I'm just
saying also the Jets ripped my heart out